Kevon D Williamson is national reviews
roving correspondent he is the author of
the end is near and it's going to be
awesome how going broke believe America
richer happier and more secure the
dependency agenda and the politically
incorrect guide to socialism
he's also contributed chapters to the
new Leviathan the state versus the
individual in the 21st century and
future tense lessons of culture in an
age of upheaval Williamson began his
journalism career at the Bombay based
Indian Express newspaper group and spent
15 years in the newspaper business in
Texas Pennsylvania and Colorado he
served as editor-in-chief of three
newspapers and was the founding editor
of Philadelphia's bulletin he's a
regular commentator on Fox News CNBC
MSNBC and NPR his work has appeared in
the New York Post the New York Daily
News commentary academic questions and
other publications
he's native of Lubbock Texas he lives in
New York City for the past two weeks
Kevin Williamson has been teaching a
seminar on the topic of covering
controversy to journalism students like
myself when I first heard that a
correspondent for National Review would
be teaching a class at Hillsdale this
semester I had a few assumptions he'd be
conservative knowledgeable entertaining
insightful the things I did not
anticipate were the shaved head the hoop
earrings the black boots the distressed
jeans the large goatee and all these
things may have striking impression when
I walked into class and two weeks later
I can tell you that he definitely earns
all of these things as you will see the
things he has to say are as arresting as
his appearance so please help me welcome
Kevin Dee Williams
these two younger no you don't actually
earn this your every year the line when
I have to stop shaving
comes down a little bit you know they
figured out who I am here at Hillsdale
because there are there two coffees
thank you all for having me out here
it's been a it's been a fun week
so there's a famous Swedish heavy metal
guitarist by the name of inve J mom
Steen who I'm sure all of you know that
first name is again it's in Vevey which
is why in GWI II he's Swedish of the
leaf and every time I see that name I
think to myself wow
Yngwie J Malmsteen I am glad he puts
that J in there because otherwise we
would confuse him with all of the other
in Vaes you're crowding the popular
consciousness which is a very long way
of getting around to saying that I'd
like to thank John Jay Miller for
arranging for me to be here one since
we're on the subject of heavy metal
guitarists and John Miller I mean we
could just do a whole talk on the
relevance of rock'n'roll music in the
liberal arts curriculum because I
understand that's what John is now
working on and my source is that the
collegian tell me that he is responsible
for a pending literary colloquium on the
on the work of Iron Maiden
all right that's pretty retro all right
but again thank you all for having me
here it's been it's been tremendously
fun week so some of you some of you may
know maybe it wasn't in my introduction
I went to college in the University of
Texas at Austin and though I think I've
had enough Austin for one lifetime it's
still City for which I have a great deal
of affection and and fondness it's kind
of really a very pleasant place and
Austin's unofficial municipal motto is
keep Austin weird and I understand and
endorse the sentiment but in truth
there's there's really nothing weird
about Austin if you've ever spent any
time there Austin is as cities go as
close to a perfect representation of
American popular culture as you could
imagine it's exactly it's exactly the
sort of place you would expect it to be
there was an article earlier this week
website called medium and it was
bemoaning the sort of creeping regnant
sameness that one sees in the cities all
over the world when one visits them I
think this particular article was about
Buenos Aires and it's not that you're
getting you know McDonald's and Walmart
and a you know sort of American
franchises and TGI Fridays and that sort
of thing everywhere but it's this sort
of hipster refinement you know that all
the bars are sort of like all the
restaurants are sort of like everyone's
having the same conversations about the
same books in the same movies and that
sort of thing and every time we visit
Austin I really noticed this because
every year it starts to feel more and
more like Brooklyn and albeit Brooklyn
with better weather and friendlier tax
regime but all state is very much what
the cool kids at the 21st century think
of you know as a city of what the good
life looks like and I would say much
more so than they actually do Brooklyn
because Austin is a place that is
certainly less stressful than New York
City but also a place that is
intellectually and culturally dominated
by
large university and for the you know
tastemakers of our time the good life
looks a lot like undergraduate college
life you know sort of an extended
undergraduate career is kind of kind of
where they want to be and I had a good
time in college don't get me wrong but
um I don't really think of college life
as being the model for for adulthood is
that an understatement but of course
when people say they want life to be
more like college they don't actually
mean this college right they mean UT and
Berkeley and places like that so you
come to Hillsdale and you meet these
kids who have worked very hard to get
here and to come to this very unhip and
unglamorous
corner of Michigan where the weather is
really nice in the winter and they've
come here to get thanks John for the
winter and they come here to study Latin
and have conversations about Aristotle
and read about Winston Churchill in the
Constitution and take history very
seriously and I didn't meet one student
in there any time I was here whose plan
was to become an internet billionaire or
to figure out a way to turn his life
into some sort of extended exotic
overseas vacation on some poor
unsuspecting nonprofits dime yeah I
remember MIT I met a girl a seminar one
time and I asked her what she want to do
in life she out of school she said I
wouldn't work for a non-profit I said
well what kind of nonprofit well I don't
know I just wanna work for a non-profit
so you don't care what the organization
does as long as it doesn't make money
all right is that is that what it is and
I was kind of basically I did meet a
number of students in my class you got
helped and want to be journalists and I
didn't discourage them too much I hope
during the course of the time I was here
but I did meet some kids who seriously
want to to try to change the world in a
way that's not necessarily self
enriching or self aggrandizing and I
think that's admirable so if and all
this happens with no inflows of
government money in which from the point
of view of Austin which is also a state
capitals very perplexing
uh-huh so if there's one thing I take
away from my for my 10 days here it's
it's for God's sake keep Hillsdale weird
and that weirdness actually is in part
oddly enough what I've come here to talk
about tonight we're a very peculiar and
strange moment in terms of our public
discourse how we talk about politics how
we talk about public affairs and it's an
environment that is in my view
incredibly corrosive and terrifyingly
insidious and there are some things that
we can do at the margins to improve that
and I'll talk about that a little bit
later in my in my talk but the only real
antidote in the long term is what
happens on this campus in places like it
which is the careful cultivation of
serious thinking there simply is no
substitute so we've seen cities before
pared and used as as meta dens for
particular worldviews in particular sort
of ethics
you have Athens in Jerusalem and in
Strauss's work in Charles mirror you
have Belmont versus Fishtown it's a
little dated by the way fish sounds kind
of a yuppie well up and coming place now
but you you get I know more about
Philadelphia than I would like to so I
think if you want to understand what's
wrong with American public discourse you
could do worse than to compare the
ethics of Austin and Hillsdale in terms
of their intellectual climates Boston's
very techy sort of place it's a very
Internet oriented place most of the
businesses there that aren't government
or technology oriented in one way or the
other
and of course I like that very much I'm
sort of in that business myself but much
of the corruption of our discourse from
which we're suffering is something that
really originates in new mental habits
associated with online communication and
particularly with social media and
before I go on I should emphasize that
this is not intended as a condemnation
of the internet best based model of
communication it's a very important
thing in the world it's been something
that's been very important in my life
and it's not only part of my livelihood
which I do care about in spite of having
been an English major it's also
something that's enabled small magazines
like National Review and others like it
to reach a much wider and broader and
more diverse audience than we would we
were constrained by the economic and
logistical limitations of print it's
just it's an undeniable thing and as a
lifelong newspaper guy I kind of hate
that a little bit I do find it a little
depressing you know I can write a cover
story for National Review and it'll go
out to the newsstands and go to
subscribers and I'll let it sit for a
week or two weeks and kind of you know
keep track of what sort of feedback I
get you know how many people are talking
about it who I hear back from and then
we'll put it up on the website for four
hours for free and I compare it with
that and of course it's overwhelming
compared to what you get online and then
if you're lucky enough to stay get a
link from the Drudge Report then you
know you're talking about a hundred
times you're five hundred times the
feedback and every now and then I get
120 seconds on Fox News to talk about
something to yell at one or whoever and
and then the feedback you get after that
is is is proportionally even larger so I
love print I really do I'd like to think
I have newspaper ink in my blood
well I print is sort of a single-shot 22
whereas the internet and broadcast
meteor more like more like a howitzer I
wish it were otherwise but it just it
just isn't so there are things we like
about online communication in social
media right one of the things we like is
that they're effectively no barriers to
entry into that market I think this is
an excellent thing if you were going to
start the New York Times today well
first of all he would need beautiful and
he mentioned I started a newspaper in
Philadelphia
but if you're gonna start the New York
Times today you know you would need a
billion dollars you know and this press
has cost a couple hundred million
dollars apiece
you know all the capital you would have
to put into would be very difficult
thing to do you would have to have a lot
of resource to do it but to start an
online alternative to it or an online
competitor to it cost basically nothing
all you need is time and something
interesting to say and an internet
connection which God knows what the FCC
is gonna do with that but right now you
can still kind of get one and they're
not not too expensive so that's that's
one of the things we like about it you
can actually get into this market really
easily
the online model of communication is is
radically non-hierarchical and sometimes
people think it's weird to hear
conservative come and saying we like
these non hierarchical institutions but
in fact it's really very important if
you have political views social views
certain sorts of cultural tendencies
that are or have been shut out of the
mainstream media then you will develop a
real appreciation for the non
hierarchical model of communication
we're talking about here you know
William F Buckley started National
Review back in 1955 to do what the New
York Times and time and life if you're
under 40 have someone explain to you
what life is later could do at the time
but simply would not do it's far easier
to do that sort of thing now you don't
need a bunch of generous donors if
you're any National Review donors
listening never mind that we do need you
but you don't need the permission of the
editors in the New York Times to get
your message out there are the producers
of CBS Evening News or or anything like
that so which is to say the model is
very democratic in a sense and as a
conservative anytime something is
described as democratic I'm a little
skeptical of it and so I mean there
there is an upside to that but um but
there are some trade-offs as well and so
it's very democratic but it's in a sense
the wrong sort of democracy it's kind of
the democracy that john adams warned us
about and that's something to keep in
mind so i mean we're all adults here we
all know there are trade-offs right I
mean they're things you're gonna do in a
certain way that will bring benefits and
costs all mature people under
and there are trade-offs and the
trade-offs that are inherent in our
current internet powered model of
communication are pretty serious and
things that need to be considered I
think carefully so the absence of
barriers to entry means that there are
more points of view represented that
people with interesting but unusual or
eccentric ideas have a much easier time
reaching an audience more quickly more
efficiently than they could have 20
years ago to say nothing of 40 or 50
years ago but also means there's no one
there to keep out the cracks in the
Charlatans and the party hacks and the
hucksters of various kinds and you know
the flat outliers which is you know ends
up being a real problem I'm having a
radically non hierarchical model of
social communication means that the
power of self-interested gatekeepers and
always used the kind of Olympian example
of the editors of the New York Times but
you know all the other media as well
their power is is greatly diminished so
we all cheer that that also means that
their power to demand basic intellectual
standards good journalism practice
accuracy ethical behavior it's also
greatly diminished those old gatekeepers
did not always use the power they had
wisely or intelligently and they
certainly didn't use it even handedly
but they did perform an important role
and there's no one really out there
doing that now so is it more democratic
no doubt it is and like all expression
is a democratic power that are unhooked
from moral and philosophical and
political guardrails it is something
that is degenerating into something like
mob rule this of course would not be
such a big deal if we were talking about
the crazy rats that your cat lady ant
publishes on her Facebook page
because you know there's a pretty easy
way to deal with that right you know
unfriend haha
you know muting blocking I actually
dumped Facebook a few months back just
as a time suck and a as a poor
investment of my quickly diminishing
intellectual resources and feel a little
overtaxed the problem is that this
internet powered model of communication
has deep and complicated influence on
traditional forms of media and
journalism and commentary and on
intellectual institutions more generally
the immediacy of online communication
has changed editorial processes in
really very important ways there's a lot
less editing there's a lot less
fact-checking
there's shorter turnaround times you
know it used to be a big thing if you've
got a story at noon and a newspaper and
you had to have it done by three for an
early edition you now if we give someone
a story at noon we want it up at 12:30
their upsides to this I mean things are
quicker more complete there's more
things to go to but there's been a
consequent lowering of intellectual
quality broadly speaking of both
American journalism and commentary
there's also the fact that traditional
media outlets have to compete with
content that is generated and
distributed for free online we hate that
by the way in the newspaper business we
really do but this has led to some
really poor editorial decision making
and I'll give you an example of that
so my hometown newspaper is in Lubbock
Texas called the Lubbock Avalanche
Journal if you've ever been to love if
you're seen pictures of love it by the
way you will be equally mystified about
why the newspaper is called the
Avalanche
it does snow there but there's really
nothing off of which to to have an
avalanche it's pretty flat no one's
really ever been explaining that to me
but uh there it is and I worked at that
newspaper for a while so in August of
2014 of the Lubbock avalanche Journal
published a piece by a woman named Carol
Morgan Carol is a local democratic
activist she writes regularly for the
opinions section of the newspapers
website and the article was headlined
Oler quote here rick perry newest member
of GOP felons club so the article is
prima facie libel in as much as rick
perry is not a felon you become a felon
at which at the point you're convicted
of a felony which he has not been
probably won't be so if rick were of
course inclined to sue over this you
would have an open-and-shut case now
governors don't generally see you nobody
newspaper colonists writing for free on
the website of the lova catalyst journal
so you kind of get away with it but so
you'll recall the governor perry was
indicted by austin prosecutor's office
for the purported crime of having vetoed
a piece of legislation she didn't want
to see vetoed because it was the funding
for her office and apparently this is
this is now a crime in texas so it's an
absurd case but even if a warrant an
absurd case it's an open case and
certainly will be for a while and
however you feel about the case the
facts are the facts rick perry isn't a
felon you don't get to call him one are
you gonna get to describe him as one and
talk about what it means for this date
of text is to have a felon for its
governor and and all that sort of stuff
it's not a matter of opinion it's a
matter of fact you can think rick perry
is a terrible guy and a dope and you can
think he should be convicted of a felony
even but he's not a felon
the same author goes on to the libel Tom
DeLay who you may recall some years ago
was indicted by the same prosecutor's
office also a kind of a silly case if
you remember the delay case he was
accused of having broken a law that
hadn't been passed at the time he was
accused of having broken it
do I need to tell you that Austin is a
democratic City probably not so that
case was ultimately thrown out in fact
it was sort of laughed out of court the
last judge they looked at it's sort of
wrote a scathing opinion on it but this
same column this goes on to describe Tom
DeLay as a felon even though he's not
he's been completely exonerated still
waiting for his apology so you've got
two people who are not felons but it
isn't stop the love a gavel in journal
from falsely and maliciously describing
them both that way and this is important
part of our public discourse people
don't know necessarily going to a
newspaper column that it's completely
full of falsehoods so I bugged the
editor and the publisher of the
newspaper about this because I do
sometimes have free time on my hands and
their stance wasn't I kid you not that
they cannot be held professionally
responsible for the stuff their
newspaper publishes on its website
because which had a drumroll here they
don't bother to edit it yeah they don't
bother to edit it so people like Carol
Morgan are generally not paid for their
contributions they're not members of the
staff and the point of view of Morris
Communications which is the company that
owns the Lava guy Avalanche Journal and
a number of other newspapers is that
these writers are simply just sources of
online clicks they're little bits of a
revenue stream for which their
publishers and editors are willing to
accept absolutely no editorial or moral
responsibility the story is still up on
the websites still uncorrect 'add I've
you know personally bothered the editor
and the publisher both about this I
don't think Rick Perry probably has I
care more about it and he does probably
this is not just libel I mean it's not
just legally wrong it's something that's
morally and ethically wrong
and suddenly undermines people's trust
in the long term in newspapers and other
sources of allegedly responsible media
so under most understandings the lawyers
and publishers are legally responsible
for what's on their websites they're
certainly morally responsible for it and
they are professionally and ethically
bound to refrain from publishing at the
very least things they know not to be
true and if they learn they're not true
they're professionally and ethically
bound to acknowledge that and to correct
these things
and and they just don't do it in the age
of internet-based communication they're
very very strong economic and practical
incentives to pretend like that's just
not your problem
to ignore all of the ethical and moral
and professional responsibilities
attached to the profession of being a
newspaper editor or a newspaper
publisher so absolute falsehood not on
your crazy cat lady ants Facebook page
on century and some odd years old
newspaper that used to employ me
actually it's kind of why I care about
it you know it's on my resume I don't
want it to but we're not just talking
here about under-resourced struggling
daily newspapers in places like Lubbock
Texas which let's face it is not the
world's center of intellectual
conversation and literacy the Texas Tech
notwithstanding Forbes some years ago
made the disastrous decision to adopt
something like a Huffington Post model
of commentary where basically anybody
can publish a column on Forbes as though
they were a Forbes columnist as long as
you're not expecting to get paid for it
so as you can imagine this attracted the
worst sort of people you know party
hacks ideologues maniacs fanatics and
and outright charlatans like Ralph Benko
now if you know Ralph Benko at all but
um so I'm gonna take some personal
examples here just because I pay more
attention to my own life than I do other
people's lives so uh Benko who's a
columnist for Forbes apparently I use
this platform to publish things that
simply aren't true things that are
demonstrably Documenta Blee untrue not
questions of opinion but questions of
fact I know this because I've been on
the receiving end of it so without going
too far into the economic weeds there
was a piece I'd written about per capita
economic growth in the United States
that he had treated as though a net
growth not you know per capita as those
of your economics students know that
over a relatively long time line those
numbers end up being radically different
so you know a pretty gross
mischaracterization of what I'd written
but um you know people make mistakes
like that all the time
you know wrote the guy up and said Ralph
you got it wrong it's actually per
capita you'll see there are per capita
seven times in the column and there's a
graph that says per capita economic
growth but you know you miss things
sometimes and so the guy turns around
writes the second column completely
ignores the fact that he's made the
mistake repeats the same accusations
based on the same thing and knowing at
this point that it's false having been
informed by me a couple of times that it
simply wasn't true so yeah I was so
bugged by this that I actually went so
far as to write Steve Forbes himself to
inform him the sort of intellectual
fraud that's going on in the magazine
that bears his name
last I checked I'll think Oh still
writes for Forbes peace has never been
corrected it's been years now and Forbes
is still refusing to take any editorial
responsibility for the stuff published
under their name that's really shocking
so uh you know on a conservative as you
may have guessed and looks
notwithstanding I suppose I think the
world really needs another conservative
it looks like Tucker Carlson Tucker's a
handsome guy in the mirror but uh so I'm
picking these from the conservative side
of the of the bench because they're in
this is sort of my side you know Forbes
is a pretty conservative magazine pretty
conservative opinions section ralph
Benko is associated with the American
principles project which really ought to
be ashamed of itself for the sort of
intellectual slumming I love it my
hometown is a pretty conservative place
at seventy seventy odd percent
Republican in presidential elections
anyway although not an especially
conservative newspaper but certainly
conservative community and things are
pretty bad on our side and if you may
guess at least from my point of view
things are considerably worse on the
other side you have New York Magazine a
very highly regarded magazine still
publishing Jonathan Chait whose
intellectual dishonesty is just serial
and has been documented by all sorts of
people myself included but also writers
for the Atlantic and
another another non raging right-wing
outlets you know the New York Times is
what it is so I had a student from the
collegian interview me when I first got
out here a very nice girl and and she
sort of gingerly and shyly asked me
whether it was the case that I actually
had argued at some point that all women
who have had abortions should be hanged
ok spoiler alert
short version no so this comes from a
publication called little green
footballs which is a sort of lefty
weirdo online publications another
exemplar of the sort of intellectual
dishonesty that proliferate it's not
only online but increasingly in in our
normal media and intellectual
institutions and I mean I could tell you
the whole story of how this was was
cooked up now I want to bore you with it
I'm generally against capital punishment
I'm generally against abortion I'm
always against ex post facto punishment
and always against lynching I think so a
fairly cooked up thing but it's one
thing for an undergrad at Hillsdale to
ask me this question I mean you know she
was probably nineteen years old or 20
years old hasn't done a lot of the sort
of reporting I got exactly the same
question a couple of weeks ago from a
senior Republican staffer in the Senate
when the Senate Finance Committee
invited me to come down and testify
about Tax Policy which is a weird
conversation you know Keaveney and we'd
like you to come down and talk about tax
law but first can we have a real quick
conversation about whether it's actually
the case that you want to lynch women
who've had abortions and yeah I was a
little disappointed you know I hate to
see that from the Republican side you'd
think they would know better but an
organization that bills itself as the
world's greatest deliberative body
apparently is reading something called
little green footballs
and I'm not thinking twice about it so
you know with friends like these so
these sorts of you know instances of
intellectual dishonesty myths lies
fabrications whatever you want to call
them proliferate and have an eternal
life and they do that for two reasons
the first reason of course is the reason
that explains most of human history
which is that people aren't very smart
there are a lot of people who aren't
very smart out there they will believe
anything that's put in front of them
that's attached to something that looks
authoritative this is why newspapers
still publish horoscopes all right
you'll actually work for a newspaper
that had an astrologer on staff we had a
full-time staff astrologer and so I show
up there and I whose office is that well
that's the astrologer is like cool I
mean that we have our own horoscope
column no he doesn't write the horoscope
column and what is our astrology teeth
he advises the publisher
most profitable newspaper I've ever
worked for in my life
incidentally so the work first reasons
people are dumb that's the tragic state
of human life people are not very smart
second reason is that there are a lot of
smart people who simply want to believe
bad things about people who are
different from them right they want to
believe that if someone disagrees with
them on matter of politics or a matter
of religion or a matter of a social
question that these people either must
be secretly motivated by some evil thing
usually the Koch brothers oil money if I
actually had all the money from the Koch
brothers and the oil companies that
people have attributed me over the years
I'd be the guy endowing this seed not
the guy here singing for a suburb ah you
know I don't know if you know my
colleague Charlie cook young English man
with whom I do a podcast who's been down
here to speak to you about once a week
someone online will describe Charlie as
the crazy right-wing Christian
fundamentalist homophobe
you know maybe in different order but
something something like that Charlie is
actually an atheist who supports gay
marriage we're working on him don't you
rob but those who Charlie's views be
these are just sort of useful insults to
throw at someone doesn't matter what
Charlie's writing about to be gun
control eyes a homophobe you know I get
the homophobe thing a lot to you and
I've just moved out of New York recently
but um you know I used to point out I'm
a theater critic who lives in Tribeca
you really think I'm trying to organize
my life around my hatred of gay people
so goes from the top to the bottom to
the bottom to the top if you go to
Twitter and look me up sometime you'll
find all sorts of tweets that I
allegedly have sent that are actually
just you know fabrications made in
Photoshop sent out by someone running on
an anonymous account and Twitter will
sometimes delete those if you complain
about it but they pop up more quickly
than you can and then you complain
always anonymous of course well I guess
except in the case of since I
naming names tonight Matt breunig who's
that idiot young socialists who it's
your rightful rolling stone or someone
rolling stones not having a good year of
it but I'm now he doesn't write for
rolling stone take it back anyway he
occasionally just made up quotes and
distributed them to me uh you know just
to sort of just great I mean this is a
guy who's actually published by
respectable publications like the new
Republican and other places so um that
sort of thing happens and anonymity is a
big part of the problem in that
particular set of situations well
because he flat-out libel and bad
standards and intellectual dishonesty
from mid-market newspapers like the one
in my hometown to Forbes all the way up
to the work of the once esteemed Dan
Rather who ended his journalism career
peddling fraud peddling a profit he was
very strongly inclined to believe she
turned out not to be true if that's an
example of why this is a sword that cuts
both ways because Dan Rather's
malfeasance was exposed by a lot of
people online bloggers dispersed sort of
media critics a couple of other
journalists operating on the Internet
and that's really something that social
media enough sort of thing is good at so
you've got someone like Dan Rather who's
a single high-profile target with a job
to lose so getting someone like that to
correct something or pointing out that
his work is erroneous or dishonest is
it's fairly easy it's one thing to get
dan Rather fired or to force Rolling
Stone to correct a story that turns out
to be entirely fraudulent fictions
fictitious but it's another thing to get
millions of anonymous people who have no
reputations to defend no editors to
police them no jobs to lose and no
professional or ethical standards to
live up to you to tell the truth about
things to engage in serious rational
political discourses to what a society
like ours needs like every other free
society and that unfortunately is is
where we are right now these are the
loudest and most influential voices in
our politics they may not be for you
especially if you're you know over 50 or
over 60 you're probably not getting most
of your news and commentary through
social media but it's probably certainly
true to kids
grandkids the number of people on
Twitter on a given day I would guess
Dwarfs the circulation of all the
newspapers the United States combined
probably many times over I should look
at the numbers so there's some things
that we can do to police that we can
develop a new social media model that
reinstates some of that lost sense of
hierarchy and responsibility and ethical
standards and that's actually something
that I'm working on myself but there's
really only so much you can do with that
because that means you have a business
model that's based on excluding most of
your potential readers and therefore
most of your potential revenue and
unless you're you know someone like me
without particularly good business sense
that doesn't seem like the way to run
anything you want to maximize your
readership you want to maximize your
revenue sources which means necessarily
lowering your standards if you wanted to
double the student body of hillsdale
you'd have to lower your standards you
just certainly would there's no question
about it
so solutions to this ultimately what's
needed of course is is a return to the
idea of intellectual honesty and
authority or at least trustworthiness
and this isn't something that's
necessarily gonna be rooted in
professional prestige if you're familiar
with PolitiFact which is one of the
worst things in American media I just
absolutely ranked despicable
intellectual dishonesty the guy who runs
that sits on the Pew let's surprise
committee which is I hear fairly
prestigious if you're listening nothing
no it isn't necessarily gonna be based
on credentials you know Paul Krugman who
is a great peddler of intellectual
dishonesty has all the credentials a man
could ever want including a Nobel Prize
in Economics Soros Jane or Leavenworth
say a Nobel Prize in Economics and it's
not really about judging people based on
errors either I mean errors are an
important thing to notice and to correct
but everyone makes errors we all
understand that that isn't necessarily
disqualify someone I made a fairly
serious error about two weeks ago where
I was calculating the value of the
median income in 1940 in 2015 dollars
you know doing the inflation to dress
the inflation adjustment I just hit the
wrong button somewhere to put a wrong
number in somewhere and I was off by a
couple thousand bucks
never trust in English majors math first
of all but this is where things like
Twitter are really helpful I'd you know
25 people in an hour probably point I
really got this wrong you need to fix
this thing you go fix it you acknowledge
your error you go on with your day you
know you say I make math mistakes all
the time the big deal is there's no
shame in making an error the shame is in
refusing to acknowledge the error
refusing to correct the error or even
worse what we're running into a lot is
presenting things that you know to be
erroneous and false as though they were
true this is a fairly serious problem in
the end this has to be based on
reputation on having a real track record
for intellectual honesty but in order
for that to work you have to have people
who really care about it you have to
have people who care about reputation
that certainly matters on the supply
side it would be better if journalists
and editors and people in media were
more self-respecting and had higher
standards and standards in media are
hilariously low I got a call the other
day from a producer of a large
television program on a cable news
network that I'll not name not Fox News
they'll say and and and the question was
we need someone who's an expert on rush
in two hours can you come and talk about
rush in two hours you know anything
about Russia and so I had said all I
have to do to be an expert on Russia and
to be on a large television show as a
rush expert is tell you that I am
apparently so I actually declined that
one although I've been on all sorts of
shows talking about all sorts of things
I know nothing about
happens all the time so it matters on
the supply side but it matters a lot
more on the demand side I'm you simply
have to have a readership that actually
really cares about these things a
readership that demands high
intellectual standards basic honesty
factual accuracy and ethical conduct on
the part of journalists and the
institutions that publish them you have
to have people whose minds are
cultivated to seek the truth
both in the common sense of that word
and the sort of capital T truth
sense that you get maybe in your
philosophy classes and things like that
and that really is the difference I
think between you know life in the
Austen ethic and life in the Hillsdale
ethic unfortunately we don't really live
in Hillsdale we more we live in Austin
well we live in a world that's governed
by fashion and shallowness and we're a
strong commitment to basic intellectual
standards is not something that that is
going to thrive in an era in which the
most trusted man in cable news is John
Stewart he's fine but you know he has a
comedian so nothing is really gonna
change I'm afraid until people start to
man that it changes and I think the only
way to do that is through well as I was
saying if journalists have to be
self-respecting and need to develop a
stronger sense of self-respect and
certainly news consumers need to do the
same as well the habit of looking at
something that just confirms your
pre-existing prejudices confirms your
pre-existing biases flatters your view
of the world that allows you to derive
satisfaction from a facsimile rather
than from the real thing it's awfully
close to pornography and I don't really
think pornography should be our model of
news with that being said I will take
some questions
thanks again Kevin Williamson we have a
couple microphones here and so please
raise your hand and stand up when the
microphones brought to you and he has
told me that he can answer any question
on any topic because he's an expert on
everything so go ahead and ask away
please stand up when the microphone is
brought to you thanks before you get
started right I just want to say that uh
you know I wrote that ending that way
because I have mentioned pornography in
every speech I've done here including
the one of the Hillsdale yes all right
class but that question is it's good and
give that the courtesy it deserves
though a billion dollars even if I had
two of them losing one would still kind
of hurt
okay anyway the second question is do
you think Brian Wayans will survive his
own hubris thank you well hope he
survives it but no more than that
well I'm not privity why Charles and
David cook make the base decisions they
do who knows there was a rumor some
years ago maybe a year or two ago that
they were gonna buy the Los Angeles
Times which was up for sale which is
America's worst big-city newspaper the
only Times is hilariously bad Micky cows
and if you fall in Micky cows used to
write these wonderful things about
here's what the LA Times missed today
you know there'll be a story about a
shootout that happens in the streets of
Los Angeles ten blocks from the LA Times
and it'll be in the Detroit News and you
know the Philadelphia Daily News and
Inquirer not in the LA Times it's a
really shockingly bad newspaper other
than Jonah's column which is awesome so
I think that the the Koch brothers
probably don't invest in media because
they don't make investments to lose
money which isn't to say that media is
necessarily a bad investment
newspapers actually do pretty well for
all the complaining and belly aching you
hear most media properties are actually
fairly profitable there's not as
profitable as they used to be back when
they were monopolies and there was no
internet and so all the classified
advertising and all that stuff had to go
in the newspaper they used to make you
know profit margins of twenty twenty one
percent you know Walmart doesn't do that
Goldman Sachs doesn't do that Apple
might so now they're back down normal
business profit margins of a couple of
points and they're all in a panic it's
one of these newspaper companies all
these media companies went bankrupt over
the last few years because they had
their newspapers were all profitable but
they'd taken on so much debt as
companies that with the lower profit
margins they couldn't service their dad
I used to work for the journal Register
company which owned a whole bunch of
newspapers all of which made money or
most of which made money anyway and the
company managed to go bankrupt
publishing newspapers
twice
I mean Journal register company's
shareholder I've got the stock option
anyway paperwork sitting somewhere which
I pull out to depress myself every now
and then uh but you know that Charles
and David Koch are people who have been
in the chemicals business and the papers
business and the energy business and the
timber business none of which are very
much like the newspaper business they
don't have any particular expertise in
media I think their interests so far as
I can tell I guess then in the interest
of full disclosure I did used to work
for the Institute for Humane studies I
think Charles Koch is on the board
they're their donors I know that but
they seem to be more interested in long
term intellectual development and also
in immediate campaign issues so if your
program is to influence the way of
culture operates and the way people
think and starting a newspaper is not a
real good way to do that they're better
ways to do that you know the think tanks
near the things that we do academics if
you're looking to change election
results starting a newspaper is a real
bad way to do that better just to give
money to candidates or to you know
independent groups and things like that
so I'm guessing it just doesn't fit in
with their portfolio anybody else yes
sir
thank you so much for your time today in
coming out and speaking to us here
Hillsdale we have I guess you could say
almost three kind of factions that shape
our political discourse and so you'll
have the Conservatives you'll have the
libertarians and you'll have these kind
of social conservative type people and
the debate always seems to come down to
how does one balance principle with
prudence in the sense of how are we to
approach me you see is gonna transition
to 2016 - with candidates like Ted Cruz
and candidates like Jeb Bush where do we
draw that line how do we articulate that
as students here at Hillsdale it's
standing for principle but also in a way
that is prudent that can get a lot more
people on the train for that mission
thank you sir hmm in terms of advising
people how to structure messages in
order to be successful in political
campaigns
I have nothing useful to say I've never
worked on a political campaign I don't
vote the long story but I haven't voted
in a long time
so I'm not sure I have much interesting
to say on that particular subject in
terms of you know in people's own
individual lives have delay balance on
various competing impulses you know I'm
someone who's generally described as a
libertarian the state to describe you as
a sort of near near anarchist probably
maybe not even here but that's a long
story too but also some of the things
that my self is a social conservative in
the sense that I care very much about
things like abortion I mean in
everyone's life you have competing sets
of values there's no there's no good
that disclude it's all goods right I
mean you guys are getting classical
education you know the argument that
Goods have to be consistent with other
goods how each person understands that
and what it leads them to think in terms
of policy issues is you know I think a
matter of general education and wisdom
and personal development and also a
matter of proportion
you know mentioned my friend Charlie
earlier who's actually just written a
book on this very subject called the
conservatory in manifesto
you're welcome Charles free plug but I
think it does matter a great deal that
sort of weight you put on issues you
know I'm someone I think so myself as a
social conservative I'm pretty
conservative on the issues like marriage
but I really don't care very much about
gay marriage I mean compared to
something like abortion I mean they're
both things I think maybe you should
care about but in terms of their
importance to the world and portal and
in terms of the question of what's
actually being perpetrated I mean
abortion is just a much more serious
issue if you believe that this is the
unjust taking of human life it's just
more important than whether you two guys
can share a bank account and get a legal
union and have some what Episcopalian
who recognizes gay marriage these days
how someone bless their union all this
rich stuff I'm not really a big fan of
gay marriage but it's just not nearly as
important an issue it's not something I
get out of bed for to be honest so yeah
I think there's a question of proportion
there to you next
thanks for coming tonight with the Saul
Alinsky tactics being used against you
and against any conservative that lifts
its head out of the above the Wheatfield
do you see the new younger group of
politicians that are coming along being
able to freeze it and turn the tables a
little bit and start to make an impact
on the Senate that should abolish the
filibuster and do the same back to Harry
Reid do you see that happening at all
yeah I hope they don't abolish the
filibuster that seems like cheating I
like to filibuster for a couple of
reasons one is because it's old and I do
have a Berkey and element I thinked am I
thinking what Jonah Goldberg would call
the Animal House version of conservatism
that it has a long tradition of
existence so so we like it for that
reason I also like the filibuster
because it stops government from doing
things and you know I love a government
shutdown you're Belgium had one for what
two and a half years something like that
I really wanted to move to Belgium so
yeah I mean it's different you know I'm
a writer so I write books I do
journalism I do talks like this and
though we like to think of ourselves as
doing something intellectually serious
and maybe on a good day I do I'm
basically in the entertainment business
right people want to read my stuff
because it's kind of fun to read and
maybe it's informative as well which is
very different from being a politician
and somebody's running for elected
office you know so for me when people
come out and say crazy and insane things
I just retweet it and publicize it I
think it's hilarious if I'm Ted Cruz or
Rand Paul or Jeb Bush or someone who's
running for Congress in the 19th
district of Texas which is my home
district you can't really do that you
know you can't really just make merry
about this sort of thing so for
politicians I have no idea what they
should do the only advice I ever give
politicians is the last line from TS
Eliot's on the difficulties of statement
statesman which is resign resign resign
yeah it stinks to be them I have no idea
what they should do though I mean me
person I laugh at it i amplified as much
as I can
I've made a lot of obscure people
briefly well-known which makes me laugh
and happy you know it's a sort of thing
that it doesn't do a lot of damage to
you if you refuse to take it seriously
you know I'm thankful that I work at
National Review where you've got a lot
of editorial support where I don't have
to go and explain myself to rich Lowry
or Jack Fowler every day where they know
what I'm doing what I'm up to you and
they trust me and so I get to district
you know laugh at these kinds of things
and it's also it's a large enough
publication that people know what I
actually believe your third and if
they're not interested in it well I
don't anything to save them anyway so
anymore
hello again um I just wanted to say
you've got all the questions out of your
system this is not a question actually I
just wanted to say on on behalf of the
collegian and the journalism program
thanks for being here and helping us up
a couple weeks and we wanted to give you
something and we just started making
these mugs for the collegian great which
is more of you know a moral gesture than
anything else but we did just start
making them so you should know you are
the first
Pulliam fellow to get an official
collegian mug awesome thank you
you know I don't actually care copies
copy in your book the the end is near in
the chapter on education you wrote that
the education field is one of the few
fields if not the only field that
confuses the product with the consumer
could you explain that a little more
well yeah sure
what's a softball thank you it's one of
my favorite subjects I say you know the
current model of public education really
goes back to Bismarck and the model is
essentially a factory the idea is that
the state capitalist state requires
people to do certain things it needs
bureaucrats to staff the government it
needs people to serve in the economy as
educated workers and things like that
and if you take a factory model of the
state then the customer is the state and
the products are the people you know you
send your kids into the factory and they
come out finished products this is a
very German idea and not the best kind
of German idea this is not the
mercedes-benz German idea but this sort
of marching angrily into France German
sort of idea and I I think this is a
terrible way to think about things
especially in the modern world where you
know factories really aren't the best
metaphor for anything anymore in an
economy like ours so in a sane and
sensible inhumane world the customers
are the people being educated what we're
trying to do is give them something to
improve their lives whether that means
through occupational training to help
them to earn money and have a livelihood
whether that means to the liberal arts
to help them cultivate their minds
making a better people now this is also
good for society I mean there's always
that argument it's better to have
educated people than uneducated people
you have to be pretty well educated to
be a citizen in the meaningful sense of
that word
but you should never confuse the the
product with the customer and I think
our you know and I this sounds like
hyperbole but it's not we have a Soviet
model of education we have a model in
which the state owns the means of
production and is a monopoly everywhere
it goes and they're trying to make it
more of a monopoly I wrote the other day
about a movement it's afoot to ban
private schools people want a ban
homeschooling because they want to
defend that monopoly and of course it
doesn't really pre bad job as monopolies
tend not to have happy customers so yeah
I think it really matters who it's not
just a matter I think of rhetoric and
language and metaphor but I think it's
it's something that's literally true
that if you don't think of the students
as being or customers and their families
as being your customers and you're never
gonna get it right and we still talk I
mean you hear Barack Obama talked this
way George W Bush before him as though
the schools were factories that were
putting out widgets in human form in
order to serve the economy to serve the
state and to serve ends associated with
people other than themselves and I think
that's just insane Kevin can you explain
more about what it means to be Catholic
in Arcis which you mentioned earlier I
believe you described yourself that way
in a recent NRO
article what does that mean are those
ever at odds well it's not the 1400s
anymore we Catholics have come along way
since then although some things still
you know very much exist the way they
always have in the Catholic world I was
having dinner with some very nice though
still folks he had me over and I was I
was ambushed when they asked me to say
grace of course you know I've been in
New York for a long time we don't really
say grace that much out there but
secondly I mean one of the reasons I
convert to Catholicism is you know we
have professionals for that sort of
thing you know I want to think of a
prayer on the spur of the moment
I got a guy in a uniform you know come
say the prayer you know I joke about
being an anarchist but it's not really
entirely a joke if you look at what the
federal government does and this is a
big part of my book if you look what
government does broadly speaking and you
measure that by what it spends money on
then you know 80 odd percent of federal
spending is Medicare Medicaid Social
Security national defense and interest
on the debt National Defense is
generally around 18% of that so that
leaves us with you know sixty to sixty
odd percent of government and maybe more
if you start cutting some of the defense
stuff that isn't really defense spending
that's pointless
that could be and should be replaced by
private sector alternatives I don't
think there's any serious argument that
Medicaid is better for anybody than
market-based health care if you look at
the studies of Medicaid outcomes people
on medical who don't have any health
insurance at all and it's not surprising
why when you think about it because you
know Medicaid reimbursements are pretty
low if you're a really good doctor you
don't sign up for it because you can get
you know better rates doing other things
so certainly at the federal level I
suspect that ninety ninety odd percent
of what we spend money on could
certainly be replaced with superior
private sector alternatives and that
includes some things like some law
enforcement activities some legal
questions
replacing some courts with private
sector tribunals and what's the word I'm
looking for arbitration yes thank you so
that's not you know getting rid of a
hundred percent of the government but um
you know I'm talking about Haiti ninety
five percent you know most of what your
local governments been money owners your
schools public schools if we had any
sense at all we would just categorically
and immediately abolish tomorrow we'd
fire all the employees burn the
buildings down destroy the records and
salt the earth
and start over again this would be you
know far superior so um to the extent
that I think that most and maybe even at
some point all of what government does
and I mean just some crazy things like
privatizing money I wish I think would
be a great idea to have market-based
currencies rather than government based
currencies there's fringy stuff I know
but um it is something that I believe in
so you know I mean compared to where we
are I mean describing that as something
close to anarchism us as I think correct
although I talked to people like he
knows for Ted Cruz fans and Rand Paul
fans who describe themselves as quote
unquote constitutional conservatives and
I think that's great and I understand
the sentiment and I endorse that
sentiment I say you really want to
reverse American public institutions
back where they were in the last years
of the 18th century okay fine if you
really believe that but that's far more
radical than anything I've proposed so
yeah I think it's all pretty sensible in
terms of does that run up against my
Catholicism not too much you know I mean
the history of the Catholic Church is
that when it gets in bed with government
things go wrong
there's nasty business in Spain there
for a couple hundred years but I figured
something I've actually I thought a
great deal about in that I believed to
be true that if you get a retreat of the
political organization of life of the
coercive government-run models of how we
educate our kids how we take care of the
poor how we pave the roads I would do
anything else how family life is defined
and organized then you've got a lot more
room for other models to grow and if
those of us who are Christians those of
us who are social conservatives of other
religious backgrounds or religious
background at all if we're right that
our way of doing things actually is
better then this should show up in the
market right if you develop truly
uncoerced soceity models for doing these
things then conservative versions of
what family life should look like what
marriage should look like all the rest
of it you all know I smash someone's
cell phone once upon a time right you
see in the story you know if we really
believe that our way of doing things is
better let's put it
test let's let people decide for
themselves organize their own lives and
see what happens
and I think in that kind of an
atmosphere particularly the Catholic
Church has a lot to offer
you know the Catholic Church actually
has a history with running big school
systems you know used to be that the
vast majority of kids in New York City
were educated in Catholic schools it has
experience with running healthcare
systems and things like that and so I
would think that in a more libertarian
environment the churches and religious
organizations and and those sorts of
groups would and could and should step
up to discover better ways of doing
things one more all right last one I met
you briefly with my husband who is a fan
of yours
but I have a question or rather a
comment and a question about something
you mentioned earlier when somebody gave
you an offer to express an expert
opinion and you I admire the fact that
you quickly dismiss that offer in all
fairness there was no money involved
well 20 bucks I'm a Russia expert
my question is why why would you not
consider looking into that area a little
bit further and I would like to explain
why I am worried about the state of
United States media and how they cover
Russian news in particular I'm Mutulu
citizen and I read both Russian and
American press and I'm outraged by the
amount of Russian propaganda that is
seeping into mainstream media now I'm
not surprised by that knowing that
Vladimir Putin spends oil money that can
quite easily compete with some of the
most wealthiest news networks in the
United States and Russia today is one of
the largest channels that air is aired
in over a hundred countries reaching
over 700 million people I can actually
watch it at home
I never thought moving into the United
States that I would be able to watch
Russian news on a little Channel not
owning a we don't watch cable but
there's a lot of a lot of young
journalists that are being recruited a
few of them could just recently because
even in their little consciousness they
were bothered by some of the things that
they had to recently air on air but what
I was going to ask you is why you
wouldn't look into that because there is
a huge need as it appears to me and many
other free minding there is not very
many of us there's a huge Russian
population living in the United States
that listen to Russia today and
unfortunately a lot of Americans that we
print without checking the sources and
reprinted and spreaded in the United
States and why you would sure that me
Alan yeah why you wouldn't look into
that it seems like there is a lot more
need America is waking up to the
recurrence of red terror I'm gonna go
ahead and treat this is a question now
yes and it's in the ascending essay
later
why don't I know more about Russia
because I don't care about Russia very
much I probably should I just don't
there only so many things in the world
you can care about my foreign interests
you're mainly India the sky star working
there in South Asia my cupboard number
that things some of Latin America I
agree with you about a RVT which is a
pretty naked propaganda network one of
my favorite things I ever saw happening
on that you all know Jamie Couric
liberal writer sensible liberal down
Jamie was invited to go on Russia today
and talk about my remember what it was
it was some us-russia relations thing
but Jamie is gay and as you know in
Russia under Putin there's a great deal
of persecution of gay folks and so they
get on in bascomb whatever question and
he takes off his jacket he's wearing
this sort of rainbow suspenders and he
just totally ambushes them and starts
lecturing them on the persecution of
homosexuals in Russia and how awful it
is and why RTV is a sort of awful
Kremlin propaganda network and I thought
that was just terrific
it made me very very happy to see uh I
mean that is an example of you know free
societies are fragile in some ways I
mean they're unfair agile in some ways
too because you have lots of different
ways of doing things so if one thing
breaks you've got other other backups
but if you're gonna have a free society
then you're gonna have people who
exploit that if you're gonna have a free
society you're gonna have foreign
governments using their funds to run
propaganda networks in your country
which is exactly what the Russians do
with our TV up you have a free society
you're always going to be vulnerable to
things like terrorism just because
there's no way to defend all the
shopping malls and movie theaters and
buses and subway cars in a free society
I'm on balance I think it's worth it to
be a free society even if that means
putting up with some Vladimir Putin
propaganda from time to time and it is
comically bad I think most people
understand although maybe not you know I
mean again as I said some people aren't
very bright and they're sort of near
anti-american slant appeals to a lot of
people
oddly enough there are a lot of people
who don't like their own country all
that much and but in the end I think
it's worth it to be open rather than
closed even if it means enduring some
things you don't like enduring thank you
all so much I appreciate it